[Music]
turns out philosophers have thought
about this for quite a while one of them
is Alvin Goldman and he has proposed a
five-level test for finding a
trustworthy expert I'm gonna walk you
through the five levels of the test this
is very useful if you get anything out
of this talk please get this slide okay
not as it is now as it will develop in
the next few minutes and then I'll give
you a application to a real case okay
this is truly useful you can go home now
from now on and and have a ready-made
tool for determining if you want to
trust somebody who claims to be an
expert or not I'm not claiming
infallibility to the tool but I'm
claiming that it's much better than what
most people normally do first question
examine the arguments presented by the
alleged expert and her rivals that's
great except that this does run into
Socrates problem that is in order to
examine the arguments you actually have
to be an expert yourself if you are
great right so if you are an economist
then you should definitely you know put
your own opinion out there about
economics but not about other stuff if
you don't understand it to look for
evidence of agreement among experts if
there is a consensus among experts
chances are that's your best bet
now agreement among experts doesn't mean
that the experts never get it wrong
yes we all know that 500 years ago
allegedly everybody every expert thought
that the the the the the earth was flat
and not round actually that's not true
astronomers have known that the earth
was round since the ancient Greeks but
sending that as that aside yes the
experts can be wrong even now even a
consensus among experts can be wrong the
question is yeah but you have you got
anything better it's it's a question of
where do you put your money okay where
are you gonna bring your money when it's
not a matter of things that actually are
important 3 look for evidence that
expert easy fed an expert when you go to
your doctor you notice I mean at least
in the United States works this way you
have they have a lot of diplomas on the
wall and the more diplomas they have and
the
more from prestigious universities the
better you feel about the doctor right
if it turns out that oh wow she's got a
diploma from Columbia and another one
from Oxford like cup this is good if
it's got a diploma from the University
oh I don't know what you can wait a
minute hold on does this woman or man
know actually what they're doing so you
can you should check for whether the
expert is a Fed an expert you can do
that actually fairly easily these days
you can check up you know on websites
the background the publication records
all sorts of stuff number four
investigate what sorts of biases the
expert may have experts are biased
because every human being is biased we
all have agendas we all have interests
we all have opinions but some opinions
and some biases are worse than others so
if your doctor keeps prescribing you the
same drug and it turns out that he
actually gets money from that particular
from a suitable company you might want
to ask for a second opinion okay it
doesn't mean that that's not a good
choice because a lot of these drugs
actually do work and they do what
they're supposed to do but you should be
you know inquiring into well what
happens to doctor that don't get money
from that from a Seussical industry do
they actually prescribe something else
and I'm if I check the track record of
the expert I mean if he's an expert
presumably was right more time than not
if you go to if you have a problem with
your car you go to a mechanic but if a
mechanic keeps give you back the car and
it's not fixed at some point you're
gonna say you know what I'm gonna look
for another mechanic right the track
record is important financial advisors
have an horrible track record this is
actually established there's research on
this stuff okay they don't do any better
than chance in the long run they may
succeed at one point or another but they
don't know Dumon and much better than
than than average random for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute of Arts and ideas
at IAI TV
you